wir fahren an die finnisch-russische
Grenze seit Tagen fliehen tausende
Menschen vor Putins teil-mobil-machung
wer es hierher geschafft hat ist erst
einmal in Sicherheit in Russland staut
es sich kilometerweit Wartezeit bis zu
13 Stunden doch selbst in Finnland will
niemand offen reden sie haben Angst die
Daheimgebliebenen in Gefahr zu bringen
offen reden kann in Russland Gefängnis
bedeuten nur verdeckt kann unser
Übersetzer mit ihnen sprechen
[Musik]
die Teilmobilmachung war der tropfende
das fast zum Überlaufen gebracht hat
es ist eine Sache dein Leben für etwas
Gutes zu riskieren aber eine andere das
aus Dummheit zu tun
wenn man in irgendeinem Keller drauf
geht für so einen irren
ich will einfach nicht in den Krieg
ziehen ich bin kein Soldat
das Ziel der meisten ist Helsinki für
viele junge gebildete Russen ist das
gerade ein Sehnsuchtsort in chatgruppen
gelten die Grenzübergänge nach Finnland
als einfach machbar und die EU als
besonders sichere Anlaufstelle in der
Hauptstadt treffen wir Dimitri
vor vier Tagen hat er Moskau verlassen
er ist einfach ins Auto gestiegen und
losgefahren doch obwohl er hier in
Sicherheit zu sein scheint die Angst
bleibt
da ja klar wenn ich die Nachrichten lese
bekomme ich automatisch Angst es ist ein
Zustand der Panik wir wissen nichts wir
wissen einfach nicht was mit unseren
Freunden zu Hause passieren wird
in Russland war Dimitri Theaterregisseur
doch seit Februar diesen Jahres ist
nichts mehr wie es einmal war die
letzten unabhängigen kritischen Stimmen
seien verschwunden die Atmosphäre im
Land werde immer bedrückender
uns ist allen klar dass es keine
unabhängigen Medien mehr gibt wir wissen
dass das in Russland kein demokratisches
System mehr ist Kritiker wurden zum
Schweigen gebracht und mit denen die
unter dem Einfluss der staatlich
gelenkten Propaganda stehen zum Beispiel
viele alte Leute mit denen kann man
nicht mehr reden
Dimitri hat einen Reisepass ein Visum
und kann es sich leisten zu fliehen
5.600 Kilometer von Moskau entfernt
trifft das auf kaum jemanden zu in Ulan
ud der Hauptstadt der Teilrepublik
boratien haben viele keinen Reisepass
und kennen den Westen des Landes nur aus
dem Fernsehen es ist eine der ärmsten
Regionen Russlands der Kreml rekrutiert
hier verhältnismäßig viele Männer um sie
an die Front zu schicken der Einsatz
dort ist gut bezahlt doch seit der Teil
Mobilmachung können Sie es sich hier
nicht mehr aussuchen ob sie kämpfen
wollen oder nicht kritiker sagen der
Kreml benutze sie als Kanonenfutter
verfolgt de factor eine koloniale
Politik wo soll er das Kanonenfutter
denn sonst hier nehmen
mit den Slawen und den Menschen des
westlichen Russlands hat man Mitleid
dort leben mehr Menschen es kann zu
Protesten kommen
die nationalen Minderheiten werden in
Russland sowieso benachteiligt und darum
fängt man mit ihrer Einberufung an
in einem Bericht des lokalen
Fernsehsenders lässt die Reporterin die
Menschen sprechen an der ungefilterten
Offenheit spürt man ihre Verzweiflung es
ist ein seltener Einblick in die
Verunsicherung die ein ganzes Land
ergriffen hat
es ist beängstigend wer hätte da keine
Angst wir gehen ins Ungewisse haben sie
ein Bescheid erhalten ja und wann
gestern abend um 11 Uhr was hat man ihm
gesagt keine Information
militärausweis wurde abgeholt jetzt
warten wir wie alt sind sie 38 ich bin
vor 15 Jahren aus der Armee
ausgeschieden haben sie Kinder ja zwei
kleine
6000 puraten sollen auf den Listen für
die Teilmobilmachung stehen viele sind
zu arm um zu fliehen und so wächst die
Unzufriedenheit und es kommt immer öfter
zu offenem Protest
Demonstrationen gibt es im ganzen Land
und besonders laut sind sie dort wo sich
nur wenige Menschen mit Russland
identifizieren so wie die Muslime in
Dagestan das tok Volk in Jakutien und
die Mongolen in boratien sie werden
brutal unterdrückt doch nicht nur dort
im ganzen Land gibt es Fehler bei den
Rekrutierungen es werden Männer
eingezogen die eigentlich nicht mehr zur
Armee müssten weil sie entweder zu alt
sind oder Väter vieler Kinder
es geht in Putins Riesenreich die Wut
der Bürger kann selbst das
Staatsfernsehen nicht mehr
ignorieren
letztendlich muss dagegen etwas gemacht
werden wir sollten die Leute nicht
aufregen
ziehen Sie diese rekrutierungsoffiziere
an den Ohren heraus und schicken sie sie
in den Donbass
Propaganda mal anders Kritik ja aber
Schuld sei nicht der Kreml sondern die
Behörden die die Vorgaben falsch
ausgeführt hätten
trotzdem im Moment kann sich kein Mann
im Land sicher sein dass nicht schon
morgen ein Einberufungsbescheid im
Briefkasten liegt auch deswegen hat
Dimitri seine Heimat verlassen er glaubt
nicht daran dass er zurückkehrt in ein
Russland unter Putin er setzt seine
Hoffnung in die Jugend
die jungen Leute sind in so etwas
ähnlichem wie eine offenen und
demokratischen Gesellschaft aufgewachsen
zumindest was Medien betrifft
ich hoffe dass diese Generation nicht in
der Sowjetunion 2.0 leben will
Dimitri ist froh dass er es rechtzeitig
raus geschafft hat mittlerweile bekommen
Menschen die eingezogen werden sollen in
Russland keinen Reisepass mehr
ausgestellt er hofft deswegen dass sich
seine Freunde noch über eine der Grenzen
retten konnten